ich fand jetzt die pressekonferenz fast
etwas bedrückt deprimiert möglicherweise
lag das aber auch nur einen
gescheiterten regina regierenden
bürgermeister von berlin hin
müller der dort auch dabei sitzen durfte
weil er eben vorsitzender der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist und was
die kanzlerin gesagt hat und das sind
natürlich die worte auf die wir schauen
insbesondere waren da doch schon etwas
dramatischer als in den vergangenen
wochen war meine wahrnehmung sie hat von
einer nationalen kraftanstrengung
gesprochen die es jetzt brauchte und sie
ist auch direkt zugegangen auf ihre
kritiker die gesagt hat naja all
diejenigen die fordern wir sollen auf
andere zahlen schauen müssten jetzt
erkennen dass eben die intensivbetten
die zahl der intensivpatienten hoch geht
und dass wir jetzt handeln müssen
gleichzeitig hat sie noch einmal
wiederholt dass die politische
wahrnehmung vor zwei wochen als man sich
getroffen hat eine andere war dass es
dann noch nicht durchsetzbar war da hat
sie sehr geschickt eigentlich mit rein
gebracht dass sie ist ja schon vorher
eigentlich wusste aber ohne
besserwisserei muss man sagen also das
war ein guter auftritt von ihr und sie
hat er nochmal die harten und
belastenden maßnahmen beschrieben was
wir gehört haben restaurants dicht
fitnessstudios nicht alles was spaß
macht alles was freizeit bedeutet
gleichzeitig hat sie aber auch betont
dieser lockdown sie sie nennt es selbst
nicht so aber es ist so sie sagt diese
maßnahmen sind nicht so wie im märz sie
hat darauf hingewiesen dass schulen und
kindergärten eben auf bleiben und dass
das ein großer unterschied ist dass auch
die wirtschaft intakt bleiben sollen und
dass man sich eben zusammen gesetzt habe
und gesagt hat okay wie kriegen wir die
zahlen runter damit schulen und kitas
auf bleiben können und die wirtschaft
intakt bleibt auch in richtung der
gastronomie hat die worte gefunden sie
hat gesagt natürlich würde sie da immer
drauf schauen und natürlich sehr doch
von den protesten draußen gesprochen
die sind natürlich wahrnehme aber sie
sieht keine alternative zu den maßnahmen
jetzt wurde es bereits am anfang gesagt
auch wir haben da immer wieder darüber
gesprochen
es gab es diesmal keine streitereien
alle ministerpräsidenten tragen jetzt
diesen beschluss trotzdem wurde es jetzt
auch nochmal danach gefragt weil man
eigentlich tatsächlich nach den letzten
monaten kaum glauben kann dass es
diesmal also keinen flickenteppich
gibt sondern in ganz deutschland gelten
also ab dem 2 november ab montag genau
dieselben regeln ja absolut darauf hat
die kanzlerin verwiesen ich glaube dass
freud sie auch besonders das heute mal
fast muss man sagen ausnahmsweise im
vergleich zu den letzten
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen eben
keine schlagzeilen gibt wie groß doch
der streit war und wie wenig sich die
kanzlerin durchsetzen konnte
gegen die ministerpräsidenten jetzt
schien besser vorbereitet sie hat
natürlich den sack so sagt man schon
vorher zu gemacht denn in den
vorbesprechungen hat sie teilweise in
die ministerpräsidenten einzeln
bearbeitet so funktioniert politik am
ende muss man in eine sitzung gehen und
sich eigentlich schon einig sein und sie
hat ja dieses papier
was wir hier sehen und was wir seit
heute morgen immer wieder in die kamera
halten
sie hat dieses papier komplett
durchsetzen können mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren